encuentra la pendiente de la función
lineal definida por la tabla y nos dan
esta tabla de aquí en la tabla y unos
periodos laborales y nos dicen cuántas
horas duran estos periodos laborales por
ejemplo medio día son cuatro horas y un
día completo son ocho y también nos
dicen cuánto dinero se gana en cada uno
de estos periodos digamos si se trabaja
en cuatro horas se ganan 54 pesos por 8
se ganan 108 pesos y así sucesivamente y
luego también nos preguntan qué
representa la pendiente en esta
situación así que hay que decir cuál es
el valor de la pendiente y darle un
significado
repasando brevemente la pendiente es
igual al cambio en la variable
dependiente dividido entre el cambio en
la variable independiente en este
ejemplo con la información de la tabla
la variable dependiente es la cantidad
de dinero que ganamos puesto que depende
del número de horas que trabajemos como
es costumbre denotamos a la variable
dependiente por equis y a la variable
independiente porque así que nuestra
pendiente se convierte en el cambio en g
cambio en he dividido entre el cambio en
x cambio en x bien entonces la pregunta
es cuánto cambia la cantidad de dinero
que gano al cambiar la cantidad de horas
que trabajo para responder a esta
pregunta voy a tomar la información de
la tabla voy a tomar dos filas distintas
y voy a comprar sus valores digamos que
pasa de trabajar 4 a 8 horas de 4 a 8
horas entonces mi cambio en x es la
diferencia de 8 y 4 o sea 8 menos 4 así
que esto es mi cambio en x en realidad
no pude haber tomado cualesquiera dos
filas de la tabla pero las cuentas
hubieran sido más complicadas bien y
para este cambio en x cuál es mi cambio
en y pues ahora pasé de ganar 54 pesos a
ganar 108 pesos así que el cambio en la
diferencia entre el dinero que voy a
ganar y el dinero que ganaba es de 108
menos 54 así que bueno así que cuál fue
el cambio en la variable dependiente fue
de 108 menos 54 que es simplemente 54
y cuánto es el cambio en la variable
independiente pues es 8 menos cuatro que
es cuatro de modo que si trabajo cuatro
horas más ganó 54 pesos adicionales hay
aquí se me había olvidado el igual y
cuánto el 54 entre 4 lo haré acá arriba
54 dividido entre 4 es restar puntos
decimales 4 caben 5 una vez que uno por
4 es 45 menos 4 es 1 y bajo el 44 cabe
en 14 3 veces 3 por 4 el 12
y ahora 14 - 12 stones bajo este cero
4 caben 25 veces el punto decimal 5 por
4 es 20 y ya no me queda ningún residuo
así que esto nos da 13.5 y como estamos
hablando de dinero igual y es mejor
decir 13.50 y para las unidades sólo hay
que considerar pesos que son las
unidades del numerador dividido entre
horas que son las unidades del
denominador con esto ya podemos
responder a la pregunta de qué significa
la pendiente en esta situación la
pendiente sencillamente nos dice cuánto
se gana por ahora cuál es el salario por
hora de trabajar en este lugar y siendo
sinceros realmente no teníamos que tomar
dos filas distintas y compararlas
podríamos simplemente haber dividido la
cantidad de dinero que ganábamos entre
el número de horas que trabajábamos por
ejemplo si trabajamos ocho horas ganamos
108 pesos así que 108 dividido entre 8
nos da 13.50 así que no había necesidad
de comparar dos filas
pero al menos así ya aprendimos algo de
pendiente